let me say three three things and I will
come to the specific point you raised
first the point is famously been made
and my belief Bob's father was involved
in making it that there are
self-fulfilling prophecies and
self-denying prophecies self-fulfilling
prophecies are the prophecy that a bank
will run that there'll be a run on a
bank even if the bank's pretty healthy
if everybody thinks the bank is going to
fail everybody will try to take their
money out and there will be a bank run
self-denying prophecies are the
prosperous e that house prices will
always go up because if everyone
believes that house prices will always
go up they will bid them up to a point
where it will no longer be true that
they will go up and that they will start
to go down I think one way of Jordan to
be safe I think one way of understanding
georges georges views is really as a
financial market and a broader
elaboration of those concepts of self
fulfilling and self-denying prophecies
and they have in common the element that
is somewhat different than the
perspective that financial scholars
somewhat sometimes take that markets
aren't just trying to predict what
reality is going to be in terms of the
profits of the company but what happens
in markets in turn affects what
subsequently happens and obviously as
the examples I suggested in housing and
a bank run suggest once one has that
element of self fulfilling and
self-denying prophecy the sense that
everything will be stable and the sense
that if you stand back and let it rip
everything will work out for the best
are not to be assumed and I think those
are very powerful and important ideas in
some ways those are the ideas that
animated much of what was done in the
wake of the depression to contain and
function a market system and with a
rather different set
institutions a rather different
configuration of markets on the global
economy I think those ideas that because
of this self-fulfilling nature of
prophecies in both directions there's a
strong public responsibility and a
public responsibility that has to be
renovated if capital is just capitalism
is to be saved from itself I think those
are very powerful and important ideas
second thing I would say is that I think
it is a serious mistake and there's been
a certain amount of this to be
dismissive of modernity and all this
trade and and all this breaking up a
risks and all this stuff and to think
you know life was kind of better when
there were just sort of banks and banks
did everything I don't minimize at all
the seriousness of the problems that we
are facing but imagine that all the
lending that took place in California
took place from California banks that
were allowed only to lend in California
think about how much larger a problem we
would have of failed institutions if
there had been no capacity to diversify
the risk across different parts of the
country think about how much worse these
problems of interest rate fluctuations
would have been if as in the old days
you had banks writing 30-year mortgages
and taking deposits that had a six-month
horizon and what happened when interest
rates went up we sort of saw that movie
in the 80s and 90s the institutions went
bankrupt so I think it's important to
understand that a modern financial
system has been created not just because
boys like casinos it has also though
they do it has also it has also been
created because there are important
functions to be
functions to be performed of identifying
different kinds of risks of sharing
risks of recognizing there's a role for
specialization our society is a richer
and better function in one because of
investments to Peter made in places like
facebook and PayPal and there's a fellow
investor I trust over time in in big in
big think as well it is unlikely that
those investments would have been made
in the same way by a large bureaucratic
build institution operating in a
multi-story building and so this concept
of a different more modern financial
system has very important benefits that
need to be recognized as we think about
the structure